hey youtubers is Charlie there were so
many Daleks in the new series 8 trailer
I wanted to do video for my top 10 there
been about 13 people to do Dalek voices
over the last 50 years that number goes
up to 14 if you count Dalek Oswin in
modern Doctor Who Nicholas Briggs is
usually credited with doing all the
Dalek voices even variations on the
normal adult lights like the Prime
Minister we saw on series 7 opener hello
to any new people if you're finding me
for the first time I do Doctor Who
videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything I've got a bunch of
extra links in the description and I'm
planning a whole bunch of stuff whenever
the episodes get here August 23rd so
before I do my list here's a quick
history lesson on all the Dalek voice
actors most people just know about
Nicholas Briggs but there are ton more
so the high-pitched Dalek voice was
actually first created by Peter Hawkins
and David Graham for the original series
that was in season 1 episode 2 it was
just called the Daleks the voice that
they came up with was modified by Brian
Hodgson to give it that mechanical sound
you can actually watch a retelling of
them doing this during Mark gages
adventure in space and time the
docudrama about the creation of Doctor
Who if you haven't seen it it is totally
amazing David Bradley plays William
Hartnell after that initial period there
were seven different people who did
Dalek voices for brief periods before
Nicholas Briggs took over in 2005 there
have been five different people to do
Davros voices he's not technically a
Dalek but I usually include the
character whenever I talk about Daleks
like father like son so here are my top
10 favorite Daleks this isn't like a
power ranking or anything is just my
list of top 10 favorites starting with
number 10 Dalek Oswin this is a really
fun twist on a Dalek and I had to give
it to Steven Moffat for trying to tell a
Dalek story in a whole new way despite
Russell T Davies already having mind a
lot of the humans as Dalek story
material it's still a little bit of a
question mark for the series and I'm
hoping it gets some callbacks in series
8 supposedly Dalek Oswin was destroyed
when the Dalek Parliament destroyed the
planet but it seems like whenever time
travel is possible and there are cracks
in the universe you never really die so
there are actually a couple really
interesting things about this Dalek and
this version of Clara supposedly she was
one of the fractured reality cars that
were created whenever Clara Oswald
jumped into the doctor's timestream in
the series 7 finale all the versions of
Clara seem to retain all the memories of
the first version of Clara so if that
were true why did Dalek Oswin not know
the doctor in a
the Daleks in that episode she just
seemed like she was meeting him for the
first time like she didn't have any
memory of him
the only explanation based on what we
know right now is that Osman Oswalt when
she was still in the Alaska as a human
knew it was going to happen and then as
a result of being converted to a Dalek
lost those memories onto number nine
Davros as played by Michael wisher in
Genesis the Daleks it's fun to watch any
version of the classic Davros seen since
the style of the writing was just so
different from what you see today
because they didn't have special effects
or huge sets all the action was in their
crazy monologues it's much more of
Davros as mad scientist's like
Frankenstein meets Doctor Who he spend a
lot more time relying on your
imagination to conjure the things that
he's talking about there was a bit of a
call back in journey's end where the
idea given to him by the Fourth Doctor
almost comes to fruition you know with
the destruction of all life nowadays on
the show as evidence during Russell T
Davies run you can just show awesome
things but sometimes it's better when
javo'''s just talks about tiny
microscopic organisms reigning supreme
and your own brain hallucinate something
epic they can never do on a TV budget
that's just a common story of almost any
TV show you're almost always able to
hallucinate things that are crazier than
what they're able to do on screen but
number eight metaltron
from series one this was the first new
Dalek to be seen since the 2005 reboot
and the beginning of Russell T Davies
love for humanizing the Daleks Metatron
was also the first survivor of the time
war that the doctor found even though
there ended up being way more than that
that the Tenth Doctor met I think this
was one of the first times that we
learned at least in the new series the
Daleks could regenerate themselves with
other people's DNA I also loved all the
callbacks to the consequences of
absorbing human DNA like the Daleks just
started breaking down mentally because
they couldn't handle all the fields in
the human emotions but number seven the
Dalek Prime Minister as seen in series
seven I always love seeing their mutant
forms every time I see one I always
think of Dalek Caan the cool thing about
the Prime Minister in this episode was
is that he was begging the doctor for
help it was another new twist on the
Daleks like the Dalek Parliament itself
every time we see them again you can
just feel the pressure behind the scenes
to do something that hasn't been done
before I know the doctor has been forced
to work alongside the Daleks in the past
but I don't remember a time when they
ever flat-out begged him most of the
time they're just trying to kill him and
the really big twist ended up being that
he got erased from their memory bank
even though that all ended up getting
reversed by the Christmas special but
number six the new white supreme Dalek
this was Steven Moffat snoo take on the
Daleks that the new Dalek paradigm I
should really include all of them in
this one hourly they were really most
notable for their reskin colors they all
had several different functions that
they never really went into on the show
so the dogs that created the new
paradigm were actually explained as
survivors of the Medusa cascade incident
I think that they mostly followed up
with these Daleks
during the video game city of the Daleks
which kind of explains why they didn't
talk too much about them on the show
after this but number 5 the Emperor
Dalek during parting of ways this was
the god emperor of the Daleks which
actually kind of makes me think of god
emperor of Dune the frank herbert's
story it's always cool to see variations
on the Dalek casings in this episode he
even had a little thrown on it they also
did some really nice callbacks to the
consequences of Daleks having human DNA
human emotions the Emperor got so crazy
when Rose suggested the Daleks were part
human because all the DNA they had
harvested he ended up creating an army
of about $500,000 that Rose was really
only able to destroy whenever she became
the bad wolf entity to be fair it was a
finale so obviously they had to up the
stakes the Emperor was so much fun
mostly because of the hubris I mean if a
being really were perfect and like a god
wouldn't it not care about anything
anyone else was doing or whether or not
people acknowledged it as a god that's
like the test if somebody tells you that
their god they're probably not a real
God wouldn't care if you thought it was
a god but number 5 human hybrid Dalek
SEC I thought of him as a bit of a twist
on the Davros character trying to
fundamentally alter the Dalek race and
make them all more human in a literal
sense
I loved how hopeful this character was
and so positive and he espoused this new
theory to the rest of the cult of Skaro
and they all just looked at each other
and said you know nope not doing it it's
a classic science fiction narrative that
anyone with new ideas immediately gets
vaporized but number 3 Davros from
stolen earth and journey's end this
version of Davros was rescued from the
time war by Dalek Caan previously Davros
as mine had been sublimated by a Dalek
consciousness so he was the Emperor of
the Daleks for a time but there was a
Dalek mind operating his body and Davros
own consciousness was just writing
passenger so whenever we see him
the first time in stolen earth he's just
retaken control of his mind and is
working with the Daleks inside the
Medusa cascade although technically he's
their prisoner so anytime you use Davros
in the story you have to up the stakes
to like really crazy levels so obviously
this Medusa cascade plot was all about
destroying all realities so that only
the Daleks were left I loved how he
ended up cursing the doctor as the
greater evil in the end like yes I tried
to destroy several universes but you
doctor you are the real villain so they
used part of his speech in the last
series a trailer not the one that just
posted but the one before that so it's
hard to say how this years is gonna deal
with him going forward the last time we
saw him he was on the crucible in the
middle of a fiery explosion but number 2
the Dalek Genesis Ark this was not
technically a Dalek but a device like a
TARDIS that existed across dimensions
and time and space housing a massive
army of Daleks bigger on the inside the
whole conceit of this was is that the
Daleks themselves needed to touch the
Ark to open it but they couldn't do that
even though they do have like little
tentacles
I really thought of the Ark is more of
like a red herring it was like a bomb
that would explode Daleks all over the
world which is kind of funny because the
master ended up using the TARDIS in a
similar way to bring the talk lefante to
earth but those things actually just
remind me of the face of bone Captain
Jack like it's this really ominous
statement about the future of humanity
like we're all destined for something
really really horrible but my number one
Dalek Dalek Caan from the cult of Skaro
my favorite Dalek Caan appearance was in
stolen earth and journey's end the
two-parter after he'd gone completely
nuts Caan is probably the most
interesting Dalek to me because at that
point he had become a twist on the bad
wolf character you know minus the
superpowers it's like he gained ultimate
knowledge but paid the ultimate price so
here's actually a timeline of events
because we seen him several times
throughout the series first we see him
in doomsday with the rest of the cult of
Skaro trying to open the Genesis Ark
they failed escape to New York in the
1930s then create the human hybrid Dalek
SEC but it goes sideways and Comm time
shifts out he travels back to the first
year of the time war being the first
person to break the time lock saves
Davros from the jaws of the nightmare
child and brings him to the Medusa
cascade in the process of that rescue
mission he sees all of time and space
and goes completely mad
I thought it was kind of funny that the
supreme Dalek inside the Medusa cascade
called him an abomination but now it's
your turn let me know in the comments
who was your favorite Dalek and what are
you hoping to see in series 8 like what
new twists on the way they tell Dalek
stories so my next bonus video will
probably post next weekend it depends on
what they post you typically they
alternate casting news with new trailers
and they just posted a new trailer if
you haven't seen it yet
you can click here I did a full
breakdown on my channel there are so
many Daleks and a Dalek battle cruiser
and you can click here to see the top 10
UK people I'd like to see become
companions at some point thank you so
much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight high fives
you